je rentre chez moi je peux pas rentrer
ils sont là en train de se piquer
alors écoutez c'est pas c'est pas une
vie ça c'est mon petit là faut faire
quelque chose il faut abattre tout tous
les mots lire
un jour hein
[Musique]
après midi dans le dernier grand squat
de Paris situé près de la gare de Lyon
vaste opération de police en effet
plusieurs centaines de Cérès avait été
mobilisés on parle de 500 600 personnes
ont été interpellées interpellation pour
la plupart de personnes démunies de
papier d'identité perquisition et puis
saisi ces idées de drogue plus de 1 kg
et demi d'héroïne plusieurs dizaines de
kilos de haschich une opération qui se
poursuivait encore ce matin près de la
gare de Lyon Philippe Madelin s'est
rendu sur place
[Musique]
près de la gare de Lyon à Paris
l'opération célébrité engagée hier à se
poursuivait ce matin dans l'îlot Chalon
le quartier était toujours en état de
siège
les contrôles policiers étaient
multipliés à l'encontre des immigrés
mais surtout les autorités en fait
entreprendre la démolition des immeubles
les plus vétustes ce qui était exploité
en général la population a bien
accueilli cette opération
c'était une chose qui fallait faire de
bien longtemps parce que vraiment dans
le quartier c'était impossible et
vraiment quand on voit toute cette
jeunesse qui vient profiter de drogue et
qui vraiment
devient quelque chose d'impossible et
que l'on voit toute une génération qui
s'en va comme ça à cause de cette
impossible de voir et de laisser faire
ça tel que c'était pas mal ça nettoie un
peu le quartier parce qu'on en avait
besoin et puis surtout il y avait un
problème de sécurité qui se posait dans
ce quartier où les gens étaient paniqués
n'osaient même pu s'absenter de chez eux
sans crainte de voir leur appartement
squatérisé alors c'est une situation
inadmissible il faut y mettre un terme
et le maire a demandé que les
dispositions soient prises pour remédier
c'est inconvénient
20 trafiquants de drogue ont été arrêtés
1 kg d'héroïne 10 kg de haschich c'est
saisi un périt hier démontre que l'île
au Chalon était devenu vraiment un
quartier à risque sa destruction fera
disparaître le dernier grand squat de
Paris madame monsieur bonsoir deux
assassinats en moins de 24 heures en
plein Paris samedi soir en algérien de
34 ans hier soir un français de 19 ans
de mort en plein Paris tout près de la
gare de Lyon dans l'îlot Chalon un
quartier promis à la rénovation depuis
1928 et où s'entasse aujourd'hui dans la
misère plusieurs milliers de gens malgré
des opérations de police répétées et
spectaculaires il y en a eu une encore
tout à l'heure l'îlot Chalon et la
plaque tournante de toutes sortes de
trafic Michel Perrault
après les deux morts de week-end dernier
nouvel opération dissuasion cet
après-midi dans l'îlot Chalons dès 15h
en escadron de CRS investi le quartier
objectif débusquer trafiquant et
consommateur de drogue
îlot Chalon à quelques mètres à peine de
la gare de Lyon c'est 9 hectares
d'immeubles qui pourrissent de façade
délabrée de tels et services de la
nettoiement de la ville de Paris semble
ignorer ce secteur de la capitale à
l'intérieur du périmètre 2000 logements
insalubre et vétustes près de 5000
personnes ont échoué là elle tente d'y
survivre ce sont pour la plupart des
asiatiques des Africains des Maghrébins
et depuis deux ans des occupants sans
titres squatteurs petit truand et
revendeurs de drogue ont pris possession
du quartier
aujourd'hui les habitants de longue date
ne supportent plus cet état de fait
il y a un an ça allait très bien depuis
6 mois ça va moins bien puis depuis
quelques jours ça dégénère complètement
quoi alors que les habitants ils se
défendent même puisque la police ne fait
rien de positif à part venir casser chez
les gens quoi chercher des propriétaires
et chez des locataires la police vient
casser un tout cassée sous prétexte de
chercher la drogue alors qu'ils savent
très bien où est la drogue je suis parti
le 27 au matin à 5h du matin à partir
travailler je rentre à 4h40 ma porte
était fracturée par la police il y avait
une descente le 27 regardez dans quel
état j'ai refait une autre fois 3400
est-ce que c'est Gaston
je suis là pour être protégé je paye mes
impôts je suis copropriétaire ils n'ont
pas droit de perquisitionner chez moi en
mon absence
plusieurs descentes de police semble
n'avoir donné que de maigres résultats
et de fait le trafic continue
[Musique]
depuis 1928 plusieurs projets de
rénovation se sont succédés mais la
procédure est lente très lente en fait
c'est très novation commence à peine et
la déclaration d'utilité publique ne
date que de février dernier
tout ce qui est entre eux passage
raginaux passage gadget
sera démoli avant la fin de cette année
en même temps nous allons commencer à
démolir du côté du passage Brunoy et la
pachalot le relogement la mairie capable
d'y faire face il sera fait aussi bien
par le Bureau d'aide social de Paris
pour ceux qui concerne la clientèle
émigrée que pour les personnes âgées il
sera fait par les offices d'HLM
encore faut-il que les loyers proposés
par les HLM soit à leur portée quant au
commerce de la drogue il n'en sera sans
doute que déplacé
de trafiquants de drogue et de proxénète
et maintenant le théâtre de réglement de
compte et de bagarre sanglante un
Algérien tué samedi un jeune français
tué hier soir les opérations coup de
poing de la police n'ont rien résolu et
la situation ne fait qu'empirer dans ce
quartier promis à la rénovation depuis
près de la gare de Lyon c'est la grande
surface de la drogue à Paris haschich
cocaïne et surtout héroïne on y trouve
tout et paraît-il moins cher qu'ailleurs
mais voilà ici ce que toi africain et
arabe et ça se passe mal très mal car
les Arabes n'aiment pas du tout les
drogués vous n'êtes pas obligé
nous la drogue chez nous on en touche
pas ils m'ont dit ils m'ont dit toi tu
es un arabe tu veux ne te mêle pas de ça
on veut pourrir la société française ça
je le dis aux Français qu'il fasse
attention et qu'il nous débarrasse de ça
ça ce sont les Blacks les Noirs
sénégalais ou autre parmi lesquels bon
nombre de revendeurs et ça les Arabes
n'aiment pas et ils le montrent
pour justifier qu'est-ce qui se passe
ici rentrer monsieur
noir Maghreb la drogue est ici une
réalité mais peut-être son trafic et sa
dénonciation servile aussi d'alibi à des
affrontements entre deux communautés à
des attitudes non dénuées de racisme en
plus la drogue c'est pas le truc des
Algériens eux ce serait plutôt la
prostitution ça détruit moins d'où les
heures et cette bouteille de gaz jetée
du troisième pour écraser un homme dans
la rue alors de là à faire appel à
l'ordre au café je regardais les
personnes tombées ici que ce qu'on veut
là ce que je suggère moi c'est un petit
poste de police où il y a trois quatre
personnes de des autorités de des CRS ou
de la police il tourne en rond 24 sur 24
je crois que ça coûte cher ça coûte pas
cher en permanence qui tourne en
permanence et
comme ça on restera tranquille ce qu'on
demande c'est la sécurité à 200 m de là
le marché s'il y avait que des français
ici il y a longtemps que le quartier
soit nettoyé hein parce que bon il des
étrangers à les Sénégalais les
Maghrébins qu'on les laisse tuer entre
eux et voilà ce soir c'est fait la
police est venue le quartier sera rasé
ce n'était prévu que depuis 60 ans après
tout mais surtout après la Goutte d'Or
après Belleville après l'île aux Chalon
ils iront ailleurs car de la drogue il y
en aura et il y en aura tant que
restaurant ce qu'il y a derrière ceux
qui les fournissent les gros bonnets
autant dire que la police n'a pas fini
de courir la police a procédé à 22
interpellations hier lors de l'opération
déclenchée dans l'île au Chalon près de
la gare de Lyon à Paris 14 personnes
sont accusées de détenir de la drogue
les autres étant en situation
irrégulière ou en possession d'armes
cette affaire relance le débat sur la
rénovation de ce quartier une rénovation
annoncée à plusieurs reprises mais
toujours repoussée pour des raisons
techniques les explications de Michel
Perrault
il au Chalon aujourd'hui 15h nouvelle
descente de police après la rafle
d'higger les trafiquants de drogue
avaient repris dès le début de
l'après-midi leur petit commerce comme
si de rien n'était
4000 personnes vivent dans ce quartier
abandonné et déshérités jusqu'à l'an
dernier plusieurs communautés français
d'origine maghrébins asiatiques
cohabitait centre de problèmes depuis
l'arrivée des dealers la physionomie
d'îlots Chalon a changé la délinquance
la violence s'ils sont installés et la
plupart des habitants vivent désormais
dans la crainte
depuis vraiment six mois c'est la drogue
tout le temps sur Paris sans arrêt sans
arrêt on en a marre on peut pas sortir
je vais faire mes courses je peux pas
sortir
je rentrais chez moi je peux pas rentrer
ils sont là en train de se piquer non
écoutez c'est pas c'est pas une vie ça
c'est pour petit
enfant
encore dans le coin c'est tout là
alors
tout démolir
on va y rester un jour je crois qu'on se
trouve dans une situation qui est
maintenant classique à Paris
euh où les administrations par leur
passivité sans doute volontaire laisse
pourrir un quartier pour ensuite faire
une opération de rénovation meilleur
prix au meilleur prix à la fois pour
l'indemnisation des gens qui seront
expulsés et pour les problèmes de
relogement et aussi pour hobbitérer un
certain nombre de d'autres problèmes
essentiels comme par exemple la présence
d'une activité industrielle et
artisanale le projet de rénovation en
voici la maquette la construction du
nouveau quartier sera organisée autour
d'une vaste place piétonne en forme de
demi ellipse sous les arcades des
commerces dans les bâtiments autour 500
logements dans 200 HLM un foyer de 120
litres pour migrants et un hôtel 3 ou 4
étoiles une véritable métamorphose mais
nous n'avons pas fait la rénovation du
lochalon pour traiter le problème de la
drogue nous avons fait la rénovation de
l'île au Chalon parce qu'il faut
améliorer les abords de la gare de Lyon
parce qu'il faut fournir à tous ces
quartiers du 12e arrondissement un
nouveau cadre de vie parce qu'il faut
fournir tous les habitants qui sont dans
une situation tout à fait convenable
dans cet îlot améliore environnement et
le meilleur disons conditions de vie
dans dans leur quartier dans leur ville
après des années d'indécision et de
passivité il semble que les événements
des derniers jours et tout précipités
les premiers coups de pioche et
démolisseurs devraient intervenir d'ici
fin juin toujours au chapitre rénovation
le maire de Paris Jacques Chirac est
celui du 12e arrondissement Paul Bernin
ont posé ce matin la première pierre de
la zakchalon une page est donc tournée
pour ce quartier proche de la gare de
Lyon qui fut pendant plusieurs mois à la
une de l'actualité une actualité
synonyme de drogue et de délinquance
dans quelques années un nouveau quartier
verra le jour avec des logements des
bureaux des commerces et un hôtel
Jean-Pierre en Kiri
cela se passait en mai 84 dealers drogué
en manque bataille rangée entre
Algériens et maliens meurtre en série
l'insécurité était devenue telle dans
l'îlot Chalon qu'il fallait frapper un
grand coup un peu moins de deux ans plus
tard la restructuration du quartier
commence la préfecture de police en
accord avec la Ville de Paris à chassé
les trafiquants de drogue des immeubles
trop vétustes ont été rasés leur
locataires du moins ceux dans la
situation était régulière ont été
relogées ce matin le maire de Paris
entouré des élus du 12e arrondissement a
posé la première pierre de la future ZAC
centraux logements sociaux mais
l'ensemble de l'opération qui s'étendra
sur une période de six ans sera bien
plus importante autour d'une place
centrale 500 logements dont la moitié
est d un hôtel trois quatre étoiles la
gare de Lyon est toute proche des
commerces des équipements publics
tous les immeubles de l'ancien îlot ne
seront pas détruits ceux qui le méritent
seront restaurés les nouvelles
constructions respecteront la volumétrie
générale de l'environnement ce
remodelage permettra également une
meilleure desserte de la gare ainsi les
vieux quartiers insalubre de l'Est de
Paris disparaissent l'un après l'autre
[Musique]